and he's the man you're saying he is
right and he isn't cheating on you it's
because he has some kind of
value
around he has some kind of guilt and
values around cheating right
i don't think that that kind of man
will cheat
even if you tell him he can
because he only has a hand
i don't think he would it's a risk
that's true actually yeah like he's
sitting there like i can fly around the
world i can do i live in shelton sorry i
could live i live in
cambridge
uh and i can do whatever i want
and i ain't cheating on this lovely
woman
and then she's like oh you could cheat
on me
no he we wouldn't
like
he's gonna start now
i don't think men lose respect like that
i again i think i think he absolutely
could be like actually she's quite needy
maybe i'm good i don't think there's a
meridian of things that can go through
the man's mind that none of us know and
do you need to do that and i would just
say no there's a lot less things that go
through a man's mind yeah snake mistaken
sex
we don't know this man as well and i
just think
it doesn't need to be touched i kind of
feel as well that like the way that he
does behave when there are women looking
at him and it's quite like i'm on it
obviously how does he behave how did he
play yeah
he just
doesn't even know he doesn't even care
he's just getting on with it i think
you're fine yeah that's
that would act on it will hide it
but to be fair when he watches this
conversation yeah yeah your relationship
is fixed yeah
so he's so in his own thing in his own
world like the he's naturally red pill
without even knowing what he didn't even
know what red pill it was he just is who
he is how did you get into it
how did you become interested in it then
was it just something that you found
when you were going online or it's it's
just something that for me since i was
really young since i was like 18 19 i
had clear
very very clear message that was given
to me in quite a harsh way okay and that
made me it was about my looks
right yeah when i was really really
young and i basically went from one day
like tuesday being the super super ugly
girl to the next day i i was
really really good-looking when i was a
young girl
um and i got a very clear message of
sort of how things worked around that
and also just being a woman that has
only
been with
guys that are of high value there's no
point to me to go and have attention
of
guys that
aren't going to give me what i want you
know you know how i was telling you that
that if i had a child or a daughter that
i would want to give her the harsh truth
of the world yeah what you learned was
the harsh truth of the world that beauty
is currency yeah it was it was i went
from one i went from
uh it literally i don't know what day it
was but it was like a tuesday and these
boys were like bullying me um i had like
this frizzy hair like i'm i'm blind it's
about without like contacts and i had
like these big glasses on
and i just was an ugly 16 year old i
really wasn't like
you know i was a really great girl i was
a good person i was from a good home a
good stable home but i was aware
that
you know these guys were just horrible
to me they would like throw me in the
river and stuff absolutely and then my
girlfriend my girlfriend yeah my
girlfriends would like have to like save
me all the time
and then
there's this one guy that kind of liked
me and he was like teased by all his
friends for liking me and i remember
like how embarrassed i felt and then it
was literally the next day like me and
my dad were just out and about and i
think we went to the opticians and they
said oh do you want to try these contact
lenses and i i wore the contact lenses
and i was really into like hair and
makeup and things like as well and i
didn't even think about that i just went
out like looking different and
it was a completely different response
i got from yeah all the guys like they
were no longer interested in the other
girls they were all interested in me
they all wanted to ask me out
and i i didn't really know how to handle
it to be honest but that's that was the
shift that that made me realize that
this is really important and nice paul
as you know like how many times have i
said oh i'm like insecure about the way
i look through it and i am i will
outrightly admit that
but it's
i got the message very very young and
yeah it's just that's just it yeah and
so i would argue that as a parent
teaching your children
or as let's say young women are coming
up right now
eventually might get this message that
beauty is currency
and you can call it shallow you can call
it mean it cannot feel good but it is
absolute fact and truth
and men have to look in the eye of truth
and nature in the same way which is the
burden of performance
men value beauty and loyalty women
provide provision and high achievement
and status in men
and as bad as that sucks and as many
feelings as that hurts it's absolute
fact
and so instead of hiding from it or
putting feelings on top of it
really good people valuable people are
brave enough to tell the ugly truth and
brave enough to put things on the line
where people are going to hate them for
it but in the end they will save more
heartbreak than the ones that lied and
tried to put things over the top of the
way the world really is
that's true but my my god kids i i don't
have kids of my own but my goddaughter
to me
is the most beautiful girl inside and
out so i'm kind of have a bit more of a
blind view when it comes to that
that's the difference between a man
sleeping with a woman and a man being
able to fall in love with her
that beautiful on the inside thing yeah
yeah i get that but like what you were
saying about your pet about parents like
because attraction's real attraction
first and then a beautiful heart too
yeah that's what makes a mane a main
chick right instead instead of so if
we're talking trees and monkey branches
the man if he's got a good woman and
she's beautiful she could even be less
beautiful than some of the branches
but if she's got a good heart and a good
soul
and she's incredible on the inside it
won't be about the branches he'll make
her the whole [ __ ] trunk and the
roots
because it's hot it's hard to keep up
keeping trying to you know always look
good all the time all those things
that's hard like that's scary a big part
of it is just getting older is scary i'd
much rather not adding any i would much
rather a woman
who doesn't add
like like justin was saying
she could be very average looking
who doesn't add any
drama to my life that's not true
sterling she at least need to be an
eight
i'd rather take an eight that i love
being around than a ten
but
that's but the less drama she adds to my
life the more valuable she is right
like because i want i want her to be my
peace
or i want to spend if i want to spend
time with a woman i genuinely want to
spend time with her then she has to be
somebody
who attracts that
she has to be peaceful towards me no not
this nagging [ __ ] not adding drama
to my life not nitpicking like no just
adding that peace and that love that's
the thing i think girls
like we we sort of don't always like i
didn't understand for a long time that
it's not all about looks because for
guys i i know it starts with looks but i
didn't realize that guys like will date
down and looks in order to get looks get
you in the door yeah
right right and i know peace keeps the
door open yeah sterling is absolutely
not lying because i have seen him
straight up kick out
dimes
that were horrible to be around these
women are [ __ ] tens and stones like
and he's not mean to him it's not like a
fresh and fit exit it's more of a
listen
unfortunately it looks like we're not
going to be able to see each other any
longer um i'll call you an uber tristan
tate doesn't like this i've seen
sterling do this to legitimate tens and
that's how it should be done i'm not
about this talking mean to women either
but i think that's the same that's the
same with with guys you could have a guy
that
is like but but for us it's not always
like about
looks i guess but it's yeah
it takes it it goes far from yeah
some beautiful women yeah i'd rather a
guy who's like a seven one of them
masculine
rather than math the look there's a lack
of masculinity in men today yeah for
sure